hi there hi this is Steve Kaufman here
the linguist on language blog and I'm
going to ramble again today I'm going to
talk about speaking and listening do we
speak our way to fluency or do we listen
our way to fluency and those of you who
follow this blog know that I'm a great
fan of listening I think the development
of the mp3 player and all the different
devices we have today has just made
listening such a wonderful way to
acquire knowledge and to acquire skills
now many people say they like watching
movies and videos and they like watching
stuff on their iPod which is fine but
I'm more partial to listening today I
was in my car for a good hour going to
different meetings and I was listening
to a history of Sweden in Swedish you
know I learned so much not only is it
good for my Swedish I learn about the
history of Sweden me my car is my
University lecture hall now it is true
that occasionally I tuned out but I also
tune out when I'm in a lecture hall so
maybe I tune out more while driving but
I still pick up a lot of information and
makes me want to go and read more on the
subject it's a two media's phenomenal
and certainly I credit the availability
of modern listening devices like the
iPod or mp3 player and the availability
of all kinds of wonderful stuff on the
internet I download some Portuguese
today on the Portuguese economy I'm
learning about history I'm doing it in
different languages using up dead time I
I would never have learned Russian if I
couldn't have mostly listened my way
through to the level that I have such as
it is so and I believe I very much
believe as I said in previous posts that
that in our efforts to get kids to read
more we should focus more on their
listening skills and we should
deliberately teach and train them in the
ability to listen to things like
mp3 players now I should apologize if I
look like I'm looking down here because
I'm tired of sitting so I'm standing
I've got one of these IKEA desks that
goes up and down so I've got it up now
and and I'm just more comfortable so I
might be moving around a bit maybe look
like I'm looking down for which I
apologize so and of course my approach
to language learning is very much input
based I see listening and reading as
related I've often said that if you
haven't heard the words it's more
difficult to to you know learn them when
you read and so my language learning
consists of a lot of listening and
reading to the same content and and I
believe we should do more of this in
schools let kids listen to the story
then listen to a dialogue on it listen
to a variety of ways of of talking about
the content matter that we want them to
learn let them listen to it often enough
and they'll learn it faster in my
opinion than if they're sat down in a
classroom and and someone has to
explicitly try to explain to them I even
went as far as to suggest that they be
taught how to run around the playground
while listening to content that's
relevant to their subjects at school
that this would get them a little more
active and at the same time might
increase the amount of stuff that they
actually learn so as I push input based
learning and input based language
learning then I come across the output
output exponents so I add my debate with
Benny the Irish polyglot and with Vince
of street smart and and they of course
are much more in favor of output and
speaking which is fine people have
different where I kind of find that
their approach let's say but annoying is
that they want to suggest that I'm only
interested in reading and listening that
I am not interested in speaking that's
not true I am very much interested in
speaking and when I have gone to learn a
language I feel that I've gotten to the
speaking stage pretty quickly that the
listening has helped me
however as
I've said many times before in order to
speak well you do need eventually to
speak a lot make no mistake you have to
speak and I even think that even if you
don't have a lot of opportunity to
interact with native speakers even such
things as as making YouTube videos of
yourself speaking in the language
speaking extemporaneously trying to use
the language is good for you and and
probably then having to watch your own
video because you'll always I mean every
time I make a foreign language video I
watch it again to see what what I was
like and I invariably find that I made
mistakes so it's it's quite a good
strategy if you don't have a lot of
people around you to talk to but if
you're in the country of course you want
to talk to people I know there is the
extreme silent period school which says
that you shouldn't try to speak the
language until you have had a lot of
exposure and you know again on all of
these things some different things work
for different people if you're already
in the country it's very hard to police
that so it's hard I always am against
imposing systems of learning that most
people are simply not going to do if I'm
in Thailand learning Thai I'm going to
go out and try out my Thai as soon as I
can and certainly this was my experience
where I lived in the country where the
language was spoken which was the case
in French although I was already fairly
well along in French I had done a lot of
basic input work at home and in Japan
where I started from scratch I mean I
would speak Japanese whenever I had the
opportunity but most of my time was
still spent on input however when you
reach a certain point where you've got a
lot of vocabulary you've got some
familiarity with the language you
continue to stumble when you speak then
at that point there's only one solution
a lot of speaking and if you then go as
I said before go to the country where
the language is spoken or find ways to
force yourself to speak a lot that does
improve your
to speak first of all because you train
the ability will speak and second of all
because it helps you find your gaps and
I'm just gonna take this phone call hi
mark can I call you back in five minutes
okay bye so so yeah that's really all I
wanted to say is is the input based
approach I believe gets you to speaking
faster because you you build up you
build up your knowledge of the language
I think that the technology available
for listening today is under-exploited
we have to do more with it in schools
everywhere we have why would I go fight
my way down to a university lecture hall
to sit and listen to someone whom I may
or may not be interested in when I can
get via the internet some of the best
lecturers storytellers in different
languages and listen to them whenever I
want it's that however at a certain
point you have to speak a lot and
whenever I've gone to a country where
for three days in a row I speaking the
line ate me up a notch and so I've never
suggested that we shouldn't speak in the
early stages of interacting in the
language if you happen to be where the
language is spoken in there and do a lot
of speaking when that point is will
depend on the individual depend on how
difficult the language is depend on how
far along you are how comfortable you
feel what the opportunities are and
there again I don't believe in the sort
of Benny or Vincent approach that says
you know we should push people to speak
because otherwise they'll forever hang
back hmm
I don't believe that I think that a lot
of people who perhaps trying to speak
too early and are not successful that
that can be quite damaging to their
confidence so far better that you take a
little longer to build up your
confidence in your vocabulary so that
when you have the speaking opportunities
you are successful and then you got to
build on that and speak and speak and
speak so it's not listen or speak it's a
question of the opportunities the
question of your personal inclination
but you can achieve an awful lot just by
listening and the heavy input strategy
that I proposed is not as Vincent and
and then he suggests because I'm only
interested in literature and don't want
to speak in fact I speak I haven't heard
Vincent speak presume he does I've heard
Benny speaking only one language because
the others he just read I'm assuming
that they are successful but I have no
proof that that their approach which is
more sort of speak early I have no proof
that their approach is more effective in
terms of getting there faster so there
you have it on listening and speaking
thank you bye